From the company who has the rights to Godzilla,
King Kong, and Pacific Rim --
so please, please, do a crossover where they
all fight each other & stuff --
Comes the best American Godzilla movie ever
made...
which really isn't saying much...
"That's a lot of fish!"
Godzilla.
Prepare for a movie that was sold as a face
off between Walter White and Godzilla
Yet barely contains any Bryan Cranston
and even less Godzilla.
Seriously, there's less than 20 minutes
of him. We counted.
Get ready for the tease of the summer,
bringing you the king of monsters like you've
never seen him before:
Obscured by water
Hidden in smoke
Barely visible through masks
Shot from really long distances on television
And shrouded in near-constant darkness.
Oh wait, here we go!
"Ahhhhhh!"
Awwww.
In a movie called "Godzilla,"
spend 80% of the runtime with two monsters
that no one has ever heard of:
This gigantic spider monkey thing
And this moth who is totally not Mothra.
Then watch as they fight against all odds
to find a safe place to pork.
Take that, true love!
Instead of watching the title character kick
ass,
spend hours of screen-time with Kick Ass and
the rest of his boring family.
There's his dad, whose wig is almost as
bad as his Japanese.
Kick Ass' wife, an emergency room nurse
who reacts to a crisis by abandoning her patients
and pawning off her only child on a coworker.
And this guy:
He's a professional bomb disposal expert
who never defuses any bombs,
a magnet for every single giant monster,
an a-hole who keeps volunteering for dangerous
missions instead of coming home to his wife
and kid.
"If you don't walk out, you don't come back
at all."
"Sir, I'll do whatever it takes."
and a hero who spends more time and effort
saving this random boy he met on a train than
he does trying to save his own family.
"I'm gonna be at the house by sunrise. Then
I'm gonna get you and Sam out."
Tell them to run, you idiot!
In a nod to the series' Japanese roots,
ride along with Ken Watanabe,
who's only in the movie to dramatically
say one name:
"We call him Gojira."
Deliver one cool line:
"Let them fight."
And, of course, stare.
Starring...
The Olsen Triplet
Discount Channing Tatum
Duhhhh
Crysenberg
and Real Kaiju Have Curves.
Godzilla. The Good One.
Man, if that's what his breath is like, I'd
hate to see his farts.